da ist ein weg
[Musik]
was ist das ich stille nacht heilige
nacht das ist ein deutsches
weihnachtslied das klingt schön ja wir
können das lied in der nächsten stunde
übersetzen und lernen habt ihr lust klar
die bilder sind toll
der coole fotos machst du auch porträts
nein ich habe auch noch ein anderes
projekt das wird super
ich weiß für ein projekt das sage ich
noch nicht sebastian können wir die
sprachübungen heute mit deinen fotos
machen klar warum nicht worum geht's am
anfang wiederholungen selber bitte
beschreibe eines von sebastians porträts
das sind zwei ältere männer mit grauen
haaren
der mann mit der braunen hose ist groß
und sieht ein bisschen traurig aus der
mann mit dem schwarzen mantel ist kleine
cebit
kannst du das auch nicht so gut
probiere es schreibe deine familie
wer gehört dazu meine großeltern
ich habe eltern einen bruder und drei
etappen
eine tante hat zwei söhne deine chance
meine songs
und wie sieht dein bruder aus
er hat dunkle haare
und
keine ahnung
er sieht ganz normal aus
[Musik]
ok
demmer
das foto
[Musik]